what do you make mark Meadows I think
there's a big report by Catherine
Herridge Stein also big news by John
Solomon but Catherine Harridge what
we've already known that what James
Comey testified to in October 2016 the
Russian lies of Hillary Clinton that
were paid for were in fact unverifiable
now they're going deeper now we know
that this woman Catholic over at the
State Department now we know that Bruce
or because of your interrogation and
Jim's interrogation behind closed doors
they all said they warned Comey they
warned the FBI they told them everything
about the dossier being phony and they
used it as the bulk of information to
get the warrant to spy on the campaign
of Trump anyway where's that taking us
well I what we see is is James Comey
went through not only yellow flashing
lights but he went through red
stoplights to try to get this President
and indict this president and I can tell
you that not only the the good work that
Catherine Herridge reported in terms of
what we're seeing what we knew but we
know that Christopher Steele not only
was talking to the DOJ was talking to
the FBI was talking to the media talking
to the State Department he was talking
to anybody who would listen trying to
talk her through or he was sending
messages to the special counsels office
he was sending up smoke signals
everywhere trying to get somebody to
take this particular story that was
false the FBI knew it was false they
knew they had credibility problems and
yet they continued to spy on American
citizens but Jim Jordan didn't he say
call me that he doesn't spy that's
actually to me here's why Catherine's
story is so important why people are
coming forward and mr. Horowitz
investigation the reason they're coming
forward is because there's a new sheriff
in town that's bill Barr and build bars
announced he's going to get to the but
never forget what he said we talked
about this on your show he said there
was a failure of leadership to the upper
echelon of the FBI
he said spying occurred he said there's
a basis for his concern about the spine
that took place and he used terms that
should scare every American unauthorized
surveillance and political surveillance
and he and John Durham are going to get
to the bottom of it and that's why
people are coming forward and Michael
Horowitz is investigation